president threatens North Korea quote
with fire and fury like the world has
never seen unquote that's after CNN
learned this afternoon that US
intelligence analysts believe that North
Korea has produced a miniaturized
nuclear warhead that's following the
Washington Post report of a confidential
assessment in which the Defense
Intelligence Agency quote assesses North
Korea has produced nuclear weapons for
ballistic missile delivery to include
delivery by ICBM class missiles and that
follows the news broken this morning
that the intelligence community has
detected North Koreans loading cruise
missiles capable of destroying a ship
onto a North Korean patrol boat this
latter bit of news was retweeted by
President Trump from the Fox and Friends
Twitter feed this morning and it frankly
created quite the awkward situation when
US ambassador to the United Nations
nikki Haley was subsequently asked about
the report that her boss had just
retweeted to his thirty five point three
million followers I didn't talk about
anything that's classified if that's in
the newspaper that's a shame it's
incredibly dangerous when things get out
into the press like that you're not only
just getting a scoop on something you're
playing with people why that poses the
question was the president's retweet of
what ambassador Haley called classified
information therefore dangerous was it
playing with people's lives as she said
the Fox News article cites quote US
officials with knowledge of the latest
intelligence in the region and quote one
official who requested anonymity to
discuss sensitive information so we have
here a president who constantly rails
against anonymous sources and has called
for the new Justice Department campaign
against leaks and he is now sharing a
story that relies upon both anonymous
sources and leaks now the president has
the power to declassify materials and
perhaps this was all planned and part of
a strategy to send a message to North
Korea though ambassador Haley didn't
seem to think so either way this could
feed into an impression of hypocrisy
that is eroding trust in this president
a new Quinnipiac poll shows 60% of the
American people think President Trump
believes he's above the law and CNN's
new poll 36 percent of the public think
he's honest and trustworthy 60 percent
do not twenty four percent of the public
trust most of what they hear from the
White
according to the CNN poll 73% do not
this president doesn't have a
credibility gap he has a credibility
chasm and as this international security
threat looms that is quite a dangerous
thing for a u.s. president to have